[Music]
so this roadkill has a relationship with
is
[Music]
then you miss them I'm trying I'm trying
pretty good up and I thought this may
sting is all it gets counter is the
reason we have plastic so I'm passing
too much weight here so I tried to
predict your what not right not quite
you see it goes right into I'm not doing
if you do we feel it's going to cause
jerking your motion if you do need you
so I would flowing hop step yeah I don't
use it go right into this basic right no
it's out to the left you see you're
gonna have to force this to get it to go
but here is local but just like you kill
it up it's the shoulder and I'm using
for the position and I'm trying to hurt
his arm if I break his arm I lose my
leverage so I'm going to go round it
with attention then his shoulder coming
down so this how must come up with that
[Music]
the hand that skips bonito stick you all
there run you still have I'll show you
in fire
[Music]
did i tell you i bypass sneaky all right
you understand does that mean
there is no need yo let's say for
example if he bends his arm
well the nikkyo came on you see that so
while i bypassed me because otherwise
they Bend on some of you have your
decayed doing it you don't have me make
sure you have it because you don't want
him bending his arm on you you see it's
there he wants to go slower him to death
and he just went into rope you see mm
one more reason to have your hands in
the right place and you have energy in
the house he is countered the nikkyo by
extending his elbow he falls into look
Benzes elbow right into the wrist I'm
not I don't have to lock his elbow they
meet y'all is walking his own
then next thing his elbows all my
ribcage you see what cut when you start
10 fines in here I don't have a base
where I need it so you push this where
here this would be like stay there I'm
gonna change the form a little come up
on your feet but brace into me you see
the difference I'm going to show you
what the other one was like let me get
there
does that make sense you keep pushing
don't take home where you want let the
technique tell you where to go I'll have
to keep my Ricky Johnson I can't
overtake mom did I create space behind
his elbow and I can't take on where I
don't have a base where I needed okay so
again distance I went backwards and you
throw it forward I'm not doing this I'm
right
[Music]
let's try doing a very common thing
what's the point of being here Dennis
okay they come along like this and the
balances you
[Music]
okay what's happening to his shoulder
it's going down he's in perfect balance
[Music]
posture so your hand wall keep it
turning keep it turning leaning a guy
[Music]
these fingers keep going towards oh I
have two ways of doing that one I keep
forcing do you see or the other one I
just keep it at that perfect amount of
pressure you get it so I'm not selling
you to keep doing that but I don't come
far out like that where I start to
extend their fingers okay so I keep it
right where it is
don't pull keep it right where it is
this hand is helping you see oh I'm not
letting that happen I'm going to do
control up the arm but I'm not trying to
crank it I just keeping it in that
perfect place
[Music]
and you've already feeling a little
question you see that it has to do with
me : or not
[Music]
you tell me
so I don't use the elbow to take you
down but when I do the quiz you see I'm
doing the same thing I'm doing here
don't pull don't push you right at the
right place where this just fits just
lay and it creates right that dilemma
he's either gonna be in Rocio or Nikki
oh that's too high right see I gotta go
like that he has too much balance all
fairness now you see the Rocio Nico -
Emma do you want to bend your arm or do
you want me to get your shoulder the
drill just don't go all the way
[Music]
I'm on that spot okay
just like I'm pretty spot something
that's where he is
it's not about it I'm not holding them
down I'm holding the posture so my
weight line is all that mid-foot not
going to be here you see the difference
or the difference right here I'll hold
that line
we already said I'm not using the elbow
depending on if you are having to lead
one way or the other is because you
didn't do the first one fully aim for
that body organization no you doing that
wish she wasn't down when you went over
or it's loose
you see it's tiny here
sometimes for safety's sake okay it
comes around a little too far you think
you got that just give it a little wider
you see I'm going to be careful because
we're not watching the zucchini salad
and technique and not inducing it for
you okay feel the pressures of the
technique
and not where you go just as I feel his
pressure wait they're not over here he's
feeling my pressure okay this way ah I
can see somewhere you are over
emphasizing a lot of the drills but look
how I am I have to Kazushi from the
beginning I'm keeping him moving teasing
keeping him moving there's a posture
if you stop tonight then you're gonna
have to do it all right they're ready
there we go and then that's gonna be
hard because it's not in this is the
Tokyo thriller that's why I want your
feet and your weight why I told you
we're now we're gonna make it more of a
coffee wardrobe I'm gonna go to here it
did with my body in my grounding
stepping I'm gonna see how I deal with
my grounding stepping I'm moving now
watch what happens you tell me if you
see my body moving and you tap when you
don't like
did you see my body right yes but if I
think Ricci that's the computer joke you
know I'm not betting his arm I'm not
breaking his arm here end of this drill
new coach you grounding step slowly
levels
[Music]
so I won't get the poke eternal if I
don't have a pressure increase okay so
push push push with your okay so
remember he's loading the pressure up
and that's gotta happen in order for
production to happen so all I'm doing
this technique is a slow increase in
pressure do you understand
so you're gonna feel like you know when
you pop a balloon you're blowing up okay
you see I want to bend his arm but he
ended up in the Nico okay here I am and
let's say this pressure is like 10 what
do you feel now
the pressure increase yeah
by increasing BC now watch tell what
what do you say the pressures doesn't
happen okay so now watch is it going up
not where it's all loose
[Applause]
[Music]
so do you have the other way to get more
slack okay
[Applause]
you see you guys are all over here okay
this is where I wanted questioners on
pressure on precious days huh now I have
to move the where I'm going
okay okay